the atlantic the atlantic and applebaum
who's
well-known political writer she has a
peace out called
the my pillow guy really could destroy
democracy
so mike lindell you know my pillow
a company that has supported this show
and many many other conservative shows
he could destroy democracy a very nice
guy patriotic guy very inspiring story
he could apparently destroy democracy
if democracy
can be destroyed by a pillow salesman
then democracy was probably not all that
sturdy in the first place
okay and and i i just want to reiterate
here
when ann applebaum or
nancy pelosi or kamala harris or anybody
else refer to
our democracy they are not referring to
democracy none of these people like
democracy
all of these people are progressives the
point of progressivism is to make the
country
less democratic to take political power
away from the people
to upend the constitutional order and
give it to bureaucrats
biden and biden's spokesman said it
clearly we follow the science we don't
follow
the judgment and prudence of the people
we don't
follow the constitution in many places
we follow whatever the egghead
bureaucrats tell us
they don't like democracy as angelo
codevilla says very well
when they refer to our democracy they
are
actually referring to their oligarchy
okay so please spare me the crocodile
tears over our democracy
when you're trying you are casting
a perfectly patriotic inspiring american
citizen all he's ever done is sell
pillows
you're casting him as an enemy of the
people
yo i need you to subscribe to my show
not just here on youtube i appreciate
that but i need you right now before you
move on i know there's going to be more
videos
go to apple podcast spotify stitcher
google play type in the michael knowles
show click that subscribe button maybe
leave a five-star review if you wouldn't
mind
really really appreciate it helps us
overcome some of the shenanigans from
big tech
we'll see you next time
[Music]
you